some were i mean some some moments where
we're not going to go through every
single speech
and you know obviously everybody out
here is trying to do their best job the
republicans are trying to
go out there and uh win the election so
i want to just focus on people that you
might not have heard the mccloskeys
for one and then uh this this great guy
maximo
alvarez maximo alvarez uh
who comes out he's another guy you
probably haven't heard of
and he speaks about his experience uh
his perspective from outside of america
then
looking into america at the democratic
ticket
there's no place to hide speaking to you
today because president trump
may not always be politically correct
he's in fact
a successful businessman you know your
average career politician
our president is just another family man
a friend and most important
our elected commander-in-chief who puts
america first
keep in mind the other guy running for
president is mostly concerned about
power
yes yes power for them
but not for the benefit of all americans
i'm speaking to you today because
i have seen people like this before i've
seen movements like this before
i've seen ideas like this before
and i am here to tell you we cannot let
them
take over our country you've seen it
before what's he referring to is
referring to fidel castro
he's referring to these people who
are now openly campaigning in the name
of marxism
even though we thought they were just
liberals but but many of them now are
openly campaigning in the name of
marxism
and in the name of marxists and he calls
it out people like to see that
we all like to see our kind of favorite
political celebrities that there's
sometimes that's interesting
but much much more important this year
we we just want to see people speaking
the truth
when he says that the democrats are
running to get more power in a way this
is like a truism right because
people run for office to have power to
do things but he says but they're not
they're not interested in using power
for the benefit of all americans
and that's true that's undeniably true
whether you think trump is
good at using power or not it seems
clear to me
he is exercising power for all americans
one of the few themes he comes back to
again and again is
we all bleed the same blood of patriots
we all need to have national loyalty we
all need to be able to speak our minds
in public because it's the only way we
can have self-government the only way we
can have unity
and what do the democrats say they say
black people can never get ahead in
america you should burn down cities we
shouldn't be peaceful
some some of the politicians and i say
by the way only some
are still calling for people remaining
peaceful
others are not do you remember when uh
when chris cuomo
uh fredo cuomo on cnn said
show me where it says that assemblies
have to be peaceful you say well it's in
the constitution first of all that's
right
right there in the first amendment but
even openly on cnn saying yeah maybe you
can be violent maybe it's a good thing
to be violent
sean king saying go out there be violent
hillary clinton saying you can't be
civil with people
who disagree with you right the list
maxine waters saying go mob republicans
where you see them where you see them in
the streets
they're saying go out there when we win
we're going to be good for our people
and bad for your people republicans
you don't this is not an issue where the
two sides are
are equal here this is an issue where
one side
says they want to help all americans the
other side said
they only want to help they only want to
help democrats
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you